[Musik]
guten abend willkommen zu einer kurzen
heute -sendung mit dem wichtigsten von
diesem sonntag sollte die regierung von
hongkong gehofft haben die demonstranten
mit dem neuen vermummungsverbot
einschüchtern zu können ist diese
rechnung nicht aufgegangen
wieder gingen heute trotz strömenden
regens zehntausende auf die strassen und
zwar ausdrücklich vermummt stephanie
schöneborn
es ist verboten dass sie demonstrieren
und es ist verboten dass sie masken
tragen seit samstag gelten das
notstandsgesetz und das masken verbot in
hongkong und gerade deswegen geben sie
auch heute erneut auf die straße
friedlich
[Applaus]
der protest gedanke von heute ist der
regierung eine nachricht zu selten
wir haben keine angst vor dieser art
unrechtmäßigen gesetz wenn man so ein
notstandsgesetz anmeldet dann ist alles
verloren heute wird es das masken verbot
und morgen dann kommt das nächste gesetz
der meinung ist auch die opposition doch
eine von diesen parlamentariern
eingereichte einstweilige verfügung
gegen das gesetz hat das hohe gericht
abgelehnt
dies könnte unser aller letzter
verfassungsmäßiger gramm im namen des
gesetzes sein
sie versuchen die menschen zu verletzen
und die opposition zu vertreten wenn
dieses notstandsgesetz einfach sehr
verabschiedet wird wird hongkong in
einem schwarzen loch zum scheitern
verurteilt sein
die proteste hat die polizei erneut mit
dem einsatz von tränengas aufgelöst
erneut kam es zu festnahmen
doch schon morgen werden sie weiter
demonstrieren gegen das notstandsgesetz
nordkorea hat die jüngsten atom
gespräche mit den usa abgebrochen und
weitere treffen vorerst ausgeschlossen
die delegation aus pjöngjang wirft den
amerikanern vor sie seien mit leeren
händen angereist dagegen erklärte
washington man habe kreative ideen
unterbreitet und wolle weiter verhandeln
nach monatelanger pause waren die
gespräche gerade erst wieder angelaufen
spd-fraktionschef mütze nicht kritisiert
die klimapolitik der grünen als
neoliberal und sozial unausgewogen
die forderung nach einem deutlich
höheren co2 co2 preis habe damit zu tun
dass die grüne klientel über hohe
einkommen verfüge sagte er dem
tagesspiegel
der grünen vorstand fordert einen co2
einstiegspreis von 40 euro pro tonne
im gegenzug soll jeder monatlich 100
euro energie geld bekommen seit jahren
herrscht krieg im osten der ukraine
13.000 menschen wurden dabei nach
un-schätzungen bislang getötet
der neue präsident sie lenski will die
krise beenden er erklärte sich bereit
den umkämpften gebieten um lugansk und
donetsk einen sonderstatus zuzugestehen
und dort wahlen durchzuführen
doch auch das stößt auf kritik viele
fürchten dass die gebiete an russland
fallen könnten
heute gingen sie in kiew auf die straße
christiansen zehntausende demonstranten
sind in kiew zum ei dann zum platz der
unabhängigkeit gekommen um gegen die ost
ukraine politik von präsident so lenski
zu demonstrieren der hatte am dienstag
verkündet dass seine regierung wahlen in
den pro-russischen separatisten gebieten
und einem sonderstatus für die region
zustimmen werde frieden wollen sie ja
alle sagen sie aber keine kapitulation
sie sagen sie wollen waren in den
besetzten gebieten aber wie soll das
gehen wenn russische truppen da sind ich
glaube sie lenski weiß gar nicht was er
macht er will nur erreichen dass putin
ihn mag
trotz der kritik der neue präsident
seinen ski hat es geschafft dass nach
jahren des stillstandes bewegung in den
festgefahrenen konflikt in der ost
ukraine gekommen ist vollumfänglich
lösung des konfliktes in kurzer zeit ist
nicht möglich da was aber möglich ist
ist das aufeinander zu kommen in kleinen
schritten und zumindestens das
einstellen oder deutlich herunterfahren
der immer noch aktiven kampfhandlungen
in den nächsten tagen soll es einen
teilweisen truppenrückzug beider seiten
an der frontlinie im donners geben ein
weiterer mühsamer schritt bis zu neuen
friedensgesprächen zwischen der ukraine
und russland mit deutschland und
frankreich als vermittler ein termin
steht weiterhin aus und auch auf den
druck der opposition wird präsident
seelands die antworten finden müssen
der weg zum frieden ist noch sehr weit
portugal wählt ein neues parlament
umfragen sehen die sozialisten von
ministerpräsident koch davon zum
regieren wird er aber wohl die stimmen
von mindestens einer weiteren linken
partei brauchen
seit costa an der macht ist erlebt das
krisengeschüttelte portugal einen
wirtschaftsaufschwung noch viereinhalb
stunden fließt das bier auf dem
oktoberfest dann ist die gaudi für
dieses jahr vorbei alles in allem zogen
die wiesn wirte schon eine positive
bilanz friedlich sei es gewesen mit
einem entspannten publikum
brigitte sei mit einem resümee
die wiesn besucher haben diesmal mehr
gegessen und weniger getrunken 7,3
millionen maß bier in 16 tagen das ist
ein minus von 200.000 liter überhaupt
feiern viele nicht mehr ganz so exzessiv
das merkt auch der sanitätsdienst es
gibt weit weniger ganz schlimm
betrunkene patienten also die
alkoholvergiftungen die wirklich sehr
schwerwiegend sind sind eher rückläufig
wir sprechen von insgesamt rund 600
patienten das sind immerhin 16 prozent
weniger als im vorjahr die besucher
wollen mehr tradition und gemütlichkeit
das teufelsrad dreht sich erfolgreich im
111 jahr im ambros schützenzelt haben
sie das schafkopfen wiederentdeckt und
auf der oidn wiesn war die holz
kegelbahn
man merkt die leute wollen dass sie
wollen natürlich auch der einen seite
gaudi haben bayerische gaudi auf der
anderen seite auch das traditionelle
miterleben nicht alles ist freilich
eitel sonnenschein 914 straftaten
registrierte die polizei ähnlich wie im
vorjahr bemerkenswert die taschendiebe
haben weniger oft zugeschlagen
da ging die statistik um 23 prozent
runter auf 133 fälle
wir haben mittlerweile international
unser personal körper so verstärkt dass
wir aus den großen metropolen sowohl
europas als auch deutschlands
taschendiebfahnder hier haben die ihr
klientel kennen nicht teil der
kriminalstatistik rund 97.000 versuche
einen bierkrug mitgehen zu lassen
wie hat ihnen der sicherheitsdienst dann
wieder abgenommen
und hier noch das wetter für den
wochenbeginn morgen im süden im norden
sonnig im süden ist der himmel bewölkt
und in alpennähe regnet es die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 7 grad
in bayern und 17 grad am oberrhein
das war es in aller kürze marietta
slomka und das heute journal um 21.45
und hier freut sich morgen barbara
hahlweg auf sie noch einen spannenden
leichtathletik abend im zdf und bis bald